st jude's ranch for children brought  brothers and sisters together today at  cowabunga bay the event led siblings  living in separate foster care homes to  hang out for some summer fun catch up on  their lives about 75 children were  joined together today  we want them to have a good time despite  some of the challenges of life we want  them to smile and come together as their  brothers and sisters and just again  create those amazing positive childhood  memories that will last an entire  lifetime  st jude's ranch and cowabunga bay have  held this event for the past six years  they do have programs every month in an  effort to bring siblings together  we'll